we weren't aware of how good sugar was I
think part of the problem too for me we
always knew sugar was good we knew he
was his talent but he doesn't have a
background like Alex Pierre like a Jose
Aldo there's nothing I can really hook
on to and go he's world class at this
but this is the new age sugar Shawn's
world class at MMA he doesn't have to
have the 80cc Jiu Jitsu wins he doesn't
have to have the glory world-class
kickboxing credentials for me I guess
old school guy I usually latch on that
stuff a bow nickel Izzy had a
professional background there's always
something from I can hook into with Suga
we saw him grow up before our eyes
completely different person we saw him
dealing with consensus did now he knew
he was special but we just didn't know
he was world class because it's tough to
filter through all this on him because
there's so much hype do you know what
Contender says there's twitch these
Hangouts takash six nine he's with the
milk boys when you get through all the
Bulls you realize oh we got a special
one here and he he did it he cemented
that on Saturday night my god did he
cement that